do you ever count how many impressions
you do have you ever knocked them off no
it's really [ __ ] remarkable I do
micro impressions now just to amuse
myself like you could just run through
them well they're just real quick like
this is Sean Connery being asked whether
he would like to vacation in Spain okay
yeah Michael Caine is a toddler a goko a
Kaka I can't say any more cuz I'm only
too bloody a so I do Paul McCartney on
Mars we didn't know be so read Tom
Brokaw asking where the library is in
Spanish okay a donde esta la biblioteca
Christopher Walken trying to open a jar
of peanut butter no nor McDonald as an
alarm clock okay hey wake up there's a
crack [ __ ] and a [ __ ] in your bed
I do Jon Lovitz as a third grader John
why do we have to use the number two
pencil Donald Trump if he does start
World War three we'll be in our bunkers
and he'll still be selling us through
closed-circuit TV we had such a fabulous
new killer okay terrific terrific our
bunkers are tremendous Chinese bunkers
turtle disasters
I'll find people with money it take
their money and give it to people that
don't have money I turn down some stat
wool sweater made some peanut butter the
hostages crisis thanks Kerry what is
this the mothership here Stern got some
coin for crane online no you're great
it's fabulous Justin you know I get
nauseous when I interviewed about things
for those renessa this is a frisbee oh
look the spaceships coming forward not
gonna dare education could you believe
it
they've all been right up I'm ready to
go back I bought deck I live across the
street you know for those of you at home
who don't know you were watching a thing
called a television the little dog died
and the dog never lived again because it
was dead
it's just that Donna duck Donna Donna
Donna duck
you